Speaker 1: I don't know if maybe there's a
contest going on between Republican senators
who can appear to be the most disconnected
from the modern world and how we talk about
things in 2021.
But if such a contest exists, I would nominate
Republican Senator John Kennedy, no relation
to the Democratic Kennedy family.
In the last month, I brought you the story
of Senator John Kennedy strangely trying to
equate guns and cars, as well as kind of equating
the regulation of guns and cars.
You can check out that segment from the March
24th Show, if it sounds interesting and it
is actually pretty interesting.
But yesterday, John Kennedy was on Fox News
ostensibly talking about, I guess, police
shootings and police brutality.
And he started talking about how we quote,
higher whites, blacks and browns.
It was as strange a segment as it sounds.
Let's take a look.
Speaker 4: There's no justice.
We can't have a society without it.
And we have decided to hire law enforcement
officials to maintain order.
We hire whites, blacks, brown men, women to
maintain order.
Many, many of our of our law enforcement agencies
are our majority minority.
Speaker 1: If you want to sound like a racist
Southerner, like if you really want to play
the prototypical caricature of a racist American
right wing southerner, you say exactly what
he said in exactly that accent, exactly how
he talks about whites, blacks and browns.
That's how you make yourself look like the
typical caricature of a Southern racist American.
In another moment, from the same appearance,
Senator Kennedy apparently in an effort to
push back against the defund the police movement,
which is supported by very few people.
He says if you don't like police next time,
call a crackhead.
That's his word, not mine.
Speaker 4: I'll put it this way.
If you hate cops just because they're cops,
you don't know anything about them, then next
time you get in trouble, call a crackhead.
Now, having said that, what we're really talking
about here, what we're talking about here
is the relationship between crime and race.
Let's just cut to the chase.
It is a statistical fact that just as it is
the case that more men than women commit crimes,
just as it is a statistical fact that more
younger people than older people commit crimes,
we have racial minorities and ethnic groups
in America that have higher crime rates.
We have to.
Poverty, but that doesn't tell you anything
Speaker 1: that is a sitting United States
senator, if you can believe it.
This opens up the possibility of so many skits
and satire on Saturday Night Live that they
must be thanking the comedy gods right now.
If you don't like police, call a crackhead
next time you're in trouble.
Why not just improve policing and then feel
better about calling the police?
Most people don't want to actually defund
or abolish the police.
Why do you need to go to what we have or crackheads?
It's a very strange kind of backwards reverse
rationalization.
The choices are police we don't believe are
as well-trained as they should be.
And drug addicts like how are those the parameters
that we should be selecting between?
And by the way, when I was preparing the segment,
I got a phone call and the clip kept playing
without sound.
If you want to see a really a scary movie,
so to speak, watch Senator John Kennedy speaking
without the audio on.
It's really the stuff of nightmares.
But that's an aside.
Now, there's like one percent that John Kennedy
gets correct here.
Don't hate police for being police.
Most police officers are people who are choosing
to be police officers for admirable, good
reasons and who never have complaints against
them about use of force.
It would be bad.
It would be a non-thinking reason to hate
an individual officer because they are a police
officer at the same time.
And this is where, you know, it's almost like
they can't hold two ideas simultaneously.
At the same time, you can understand that
all officers can be part of a system that
is not productively serving a large portion
of the people in their respective communities
and that there are changes there that need
to be made.
None of it involves crackheads.
None of it involves drug addicts of any kind.
Now, I know that the caricature is the left
just wants to end police or defund the police
or cancel police or whatever.
There are some who want to do that.
Most don't.
We have the public polling data on it.
What most people want is to reform and restructure
the police.
And I know that there are some on the left,
including in my audience, who get mad and
they say reform has never worked.
Why would it work now?
Well, we've not actually done it.
And there are police unions that get in the
way of certain reform, elements that are often
recommended and suggested, including a national
bad actors database, that police departments
be mandated to both report to the Bad Actors
database, as well as to use it for reference
when hiring a new police officer.
I have multiple segments with ten or twelve
possible specific reforms.
Most people just want to improve policing.
There are situations where you don't need
an armed officer to show up.
There are situations that are better deescalated
by social workers and others.
But we could also give police officers better
training as social workers.
That's another great idea.
Better equip them for de-escalation.
In many countries, police are much better
trained for de-escalation.
None of it requires crackheads, and none of
it requires defunding or canceling the police